up guys welcome to the just pearly
things youtube channel today um
i actually decided to
i put the stream yard link in the chat
and i wanted to invite you guys and see
if anyone wanted to hop on with me
um in terms of topic this is like pretty
last minute i just kind of had the idea
to do it today so
we can really talk about anything i've
talked about on the channel the last
couple of weeks because
um
or like ever to be honest
i don't really care i was just curious
if anyone would join to be honest but
the thing is i'm gonna tell you the one
thing
i don't know how to fix this like black
bar
around
like i don't know how to fix it it's
because i'm using my canon camera
look at the quality great
but the black bar i don't know how to
get rid of
um
okay the move has been oh my gosh so
stressful like i didn't have power
for like two or three days when i first
got here and then i woke up today
and i had no power and i spent like half
the day trying to get power
and
oh my gosh
oh my gosh and then like i had issues
with the wi-fi like when you change
countries there are a million things
that you have to think about that like
you just are not going to think about
until you get here
like for example here's one
um i brought my pc because it's like a
couple thousand dollars
and i didn't know i'd have to spend 100
pounds which is like 150 bucks
on a power supply converter so i don't
know it's just like stuff like that
what's up from chicago um
how is my day it's good it's like 2 and
32 three in the morning here
my bad sleep habits don't change no
matter where i'm at
um i'm gonna pin
oh wait i guess i can't pin it but i
wanted to pin the
url what's on my mind um
you know what's been on my mind lately
the
travis scott concert i've been debating
like if i think it's really like if he's
responsible in any way for what happened
um
and pros and cons right i mean clearly i
don't think he knew anyone was dying i
think
that if travis like knew that people
were dying he probably would have
stopped the
concert um
so i should probably tell you guys what
happened
um travis scott what you guys might have
heard already but travis scott was
doing a concert and basically like the
crowd was so um compact that people were
literally like suffocating
and people like got trampled people um
like i think eight people died of either
like heat exhaustion or like getting
trampled or whatever
um
and some like people were mad because
people were shouting at him to like stop
the show and he just kept going
um
i don't think he probably didn't know
people were dying i think if he knew
people were like actually dying um
he probably would have stopped the show
i think if you've been to any concert
like
the paramedics come all the time um
like you know people get too drunk
people do stupid stuff
whatever but
then i find out that
he's actually gotten in trouble for
stuff like this before
like i think four or five years ago he
got arrested for like basically doing
something similar i think he incited the
crowd a little more back then um like he
was telling them to go like to the front
or whatever
but he has actually gotten in trouble
for starting a riot
so
that makes it like a little sketch
um
i feel like he's not to blame i feel
like he was irresponsible um
i
i think when he i think like
there were probably some indicators
that he should have stopped early that
he chose to ignore
not thinking there was going to be like
that big of a consequence that's kind of
how i would take it like i think he was
irresponsible but i don't think he was
responsible
does that make sense like i think what
he did was irresponsible but
do i think he's like
to blame for those people's death
no of course not
i should have brought a water over here
i'd love it if some of you guys joined
i've never had anyone join a youtube
live stream before
never
i'm gonna do like a more organized
version of this
at some point i just kind of wanted to
try it out because i just figured out
how everyone like streams
what i haven't figured out is how to get
rid of this black bar around me if
anyone knows how to do that let me know
the venue so to blame for not stopping
the show
um
yeah i would say it's yeah
um
that's the way his concerts go though
everybody knows that he insights the
crowd to go wild and break and then
break everything i don't know enough
about his concerts to really
say that um
i've never heard of him like trying
telling people to break stuff but
just because he does that regularly i
don't think
like if anything that makes him more to
blame because he's he's seen what's
happened before
um
but yeah i don't know that's what i've
been thinking about a lot lately is just
how crazy that situation was
i can't even imagine like getting
suffocated from that many people like
being so close because
i didn't think about that people
like if you get out of the crowd or like
you fall or something
literally like a bunch of people are
gonna fall on top of you because
like it's so compact and so tight
like that's crazy to me
live yeah i'm gonna be doing lives more
often
i am actually so excited to just kill
youtube
i feel like the last couple of months i
have been so distracted with
oh my gosh just life like trying to get
here and like
a million other like things i had to
plan that now that i'm here i just want
to like
get going thank you for the dollar
also i'm gonna put the link in the chat
consider buying one of my sweatshirts if
you like
if you enjoy my channel because
because i'm sorry i was reading that
comment because
um i have to sell a certain amount in
order for them to like
even ship so i have to they're only open
for like four more days but yeah
let's see one dollar but seriously every
dollar helps me so much
the
move had so many hidden expenses that i
was not ready for
okay
like do you guys know what they did the
uk government bamboozled me
they bamboozled me okay
i i show up to the uk i'm excited right
bags in my hand
stressed out don't get me wrong but
excited i have my dog on the plane right
i'm
bringing her
off the plane
and they tell me this guy stops me and
he says hannah davis anyone that's been
following my channel for a while knows
my first name is actually hannah so i i
like pull up and i'm like what's going
on and he he's like going through the
paperwork with my dog
yeah my dog is on the floor um maybe i
can show you
um
okay i don't really want to move this
too much but okay so i show up and then
he's like
basically tells me that i have to pay a
fee and i'm like that's funny i didn't
know about i didn't know about a fee
like nobody told me about a fee
and this man tells me i have to
spend
like 600 pounds which is like 800
american dollars
just to get my dog in the country so
either
either he's going to take away my dog
forever or
i can pay him 800 pounds
like what what are my options here like
what
so like that that was an expense and
furnishing my apartment like oh my god
it was so much more expensive than i
thought and i didn't really like my
apartment you hear the echo like my
apartment is echoey
um okay
am i able to add designs
yeah if you have an idea for one i can
maybe talk to them i've gotten that a
lot actually that they people want like
more stuff on my sweatshirts
um so i was thinking about like talking
to them about that
i should adopt in england no
no i i wish i didn't i mean i love my
dog
and part of me is glad i got her but i i
wish i got her when i was 30 to be
honest
because it's just like a lot sometimes
um
oh you were streaming at 570p
um
wait so how do i switch that
you're streaming at 570p at 1080.
see i don't know how to switch it
but
i'll try to find it out for the next
stream i just like could not figure out
how to do it today
do i see myself living in england for
the long run um no
no i mean i'd say a couple like the plan
is a year i'd say a couple years like at
most if like it really worked out but
like right now the plan is to stay for a
year and then go back
um
because the master's program i'm in
takes a year
it's kind of hard because as a girl you
kind of have to think about like your
biological clock a little more
and
like i probably would have a decent
amount of like
like playing opportunities overseas um
for volleyball like i could probably go
pro next year if i wanted to but like
you got to think about like if you want
to have kids and like get married and
just like it kind of sucks to be honest
on some level because
like that always has to be in the back
of your mind
you can't just
like do whatever you want
um
dogs are more of a hassle than
kids i do not think so
can you dunk a basketball
ah no no i cannot i wish
i would have made it a lot further in my
basketball career if i could do that
be honest
with what
the the basketball thing
yeah i could
i cannot
have i ever been to japan yeah when i
was like 12 my mom shipped me off to
japan like by myself
like literally alone she just like put
me on a plane
and
yeah and i stayed with like her friend
from high school for like
two weeks
um
okay i don't i did play soccer in high
school i was bad i wasn't good
um i also don't really like being
outside that long so
do i watch football and no
no but i was thinking about doing a
series of like
like reacting to sports reactions
even though i hate sports like i
literally hate watching i don't even
watch basketball or volleyball like i
hate watching sports
but i was thinking that it'd be funny to
like
you know
like react as someone like really dumb
when it comes to that stuff
um
maybe she was hoping the japanese
emphasis on education rubbed off on you
yeah she probably was
but yeah they took school so seriously
there i remember i went there i went
during the summer and they only have
like a two-week summer
and the kids would literally
just
like be on their
like
doing their homework like the whole time
like i was so bored
um am i on twitch no but if i was to be
on twitch would you watch
and i don't actually know anything about
twitch so like what would i stream
try an afl reaction
i don't know what that is afl
my favorite thing to do
afl but if you guys have clips you want
me to react to or videos i'm actually
like
really low on stuff to react to so if
you have any ideas like
send it to my instagram
because like i seriously need stuff to
react to
um
lfl i don't know what that is
um
am i playing volleyball yeah i'm getting
to play both right now but volleyball is
a lot more competitive at the school
that i'm at so i'm playing that but
there's basketball here too
um
well let me look up wheat waffles last
video and i'll tell you
i think
it looks like i watched half of it
okay you can't you can't see but you'll
have to take my word
um
i actually like wheat waffles because
even though he
he's trashed me a little bit to be
honest i don't remember what he did
exactly because i didn't care that much
but i like saw a couple comments where
he was i think calling me a grifter
was that i don't even remember but
even i don't even care because even if
people trash me like if i like their
content i like their content i'm not
about to
switch up
just because
of that but anyways
i like him because i think he gives the
black pill like a better name
because he he's like more normal
like a lot of the black colors are kind
of weird
um
just because like a lot of them it's
like
doom or gloom you know like there's no
solution
and weave waffles like really isn't like
that
okay
um what is my favorite thing to do in my
free time i literally love
youtube i love music and i love playing
sports
that's like
the three things i love to do more than
anything to be honest and hanging out
with friends obviously
look at it it's okay to be weird guys
i'm weird but
you just gotta own it sorry black pill
is kind of weird
but the whole manosphere is kind of
weird to be honest like sometimes i'll
be talking about certain topics
like with my friends or with random
people and i realize like
why everyone else
thinks we're weird to be honest
um
we will
will you see
we will
wait will we see you in the olympics for
volleyball in the future
no i wish i wanted to be an olympian but
no
um
just realistically like
i didn't go to a division one school
like and you you have to go to a
division one school and be the best at
the division one schools i could have
went to a division one small school in
the middle of nowhere
or like losing school but i didn't want
to do that so i picked like a top 20
ranked d3
program
um
which was super great i'm glad i did it
but like odds of me going to the
olympics
negative
naysky
um do i watch fresh and fit i haven't
really since i've been on the show
there's a couple clips i've seen but
not like i used to
but honestly i've been preoccupied with
this move man
i have been
what time is it here it's almost three
i should join scott adams on a few of
his talks what is he
i only really tune into him on election
season is he like doing interviews and
stuff now i love scott adams though
actually
i used to listen to him like every day
during election season
i don't think he has anyone on his talks
oh my gosh his channel has died a little
bit
it's kind of weird to see myself like
i'm at 20 000 subscribers
and it's a little weird to like
see myself
getting like closer
to like these youtubers that like i used
to watch growing up
um
how do i become a 0 out of 10 without
makeup
you are gonna be blocked
um
and i would at least give myself a two
thank you like maybe a three
sheesh
um
how was the food
bad i have not tasted anything that was
that good here
if you ran out of content can you guys
hear my dog snoring
she's definitely snoring right behind me
can you be a mod
uh i don't know how to make you a mod
am i a viking blood i don't know
you're in britain yes i am
i was supposed to go to england to see
how it is
i know a friend he said birmingham
england is more safe and the least
expensive yeah
i have spent so much money on this move
oh my god like thousands of dollars more
like
i you guys are gonna see a lot of
content because i am broke right now i'm
so broke oh my god
react to
rope dart
yeah send it to my instagram
i'm actually like i
read all my messages on instagram i
might not actually like respond to you
guys but i see all the
like if you guys send actual links to me
um
okay how do you react to movies because
i would just imagine like that would be
copyright
how do people react to movies
did my family come with you me no my
family's in the u.s my mom came with me
to help me move oh my gosh that was like
one of the nicest things she's ever done
like two days she just like randomly
decided to come with me to britain
have i practiced guitar lately my guitar
came in the mail today i just ordered
one i was practicing today but before
that no
because i didn't have a guitar but now i
do
also guys the link is in the chat
the link is in the chat it's the last
message consider buying one of my
sweatshirts they're cool sweatshirts
they go with anything
they're super plain right i'm i'm a
plain type of [ __ ] i like plain stuff
but if you like my channel if you've
been watching for a couple months now
copper sweatshirt i need to sell like 35
of each design
in order
in order to um
like i like actually ship them out
otherwise people get refunded
so
like consider it please it'd be nice
um and all the money i make from these
sweatshirts goes directly to the channel
so i'm trying to buy equipment for
public interviews that is what it would
be going to
um
commentary is not copyright you just got
to pause the video every 10 seconds
oh my god 10 seconds
sheesh
isn't that so broken up
that's we have to edit videos for movie
reactions
can you send me an example of one
because i really
have to see how that would work
um
okay
i like this girl so much i decided to
push her down and throw dirt on her to
assert my dominance and show her i don't
need her do i think it will work
hubert hubert
i think that's a great plan
let me know how it goes for you record
it if you can
um let me know in great detail
you'd have to pause every eight seconds
like donna donovan sharp does and break
up the audio so the algorithm doesn't
catch it so easily
do i have freckles yeah i do
um right now my face is like very broken
out so this is just acne but
i don't really go out in the sun too
much but i do have freckles
movie recapped does something like that
yeah send me examples
i'm telling you
when i get like a good amount of links
i'm just going to go crazy with these
reactions because
i haven't gotten requests in a while so
i'm kind of waiting for people to send
me some but
i
i'm broke
um
okay
which would be better to escalate to
make a move after initial wait
do you have a 12 string this time or a
six i have the same one i had before
six i guess
um okay which would be better to
escalate to make a move after inviting a
woman back to your apartment or talk
dirty during the date oh and then
invite her to your apartment
um
oh gosh
i don't know
i mean i'd say flirt with her during the
date don't if it depends what date is it
is it the first day or the fifth date
because
very different rules
very different rules
um have i ever seen a raccoon no
people what
okay have i landed a job
this is my job
this the what i'm doing now
okay first date or third date i mean i
would say like
like flirt with her a little bit during
the day like make sure you like you're
touching her not in a weird way but just
like touching her arm like maintaining
like contact during the date
and like tease her a little bit like
you know give her give her a little [ __ ]
like girls girls like to be teased a
little bit
oh my gosh the jet engine sound that is
the
the washer
here like it's so loud
uh e
sometimes i have to say things in my
head to make sure you guys aren't trying
to make me say like a swear word
has my boyfriend visited no i've only
been here like three weeks
like that's literally it
i don't even think i've been here three
full weeks yet plus i'm going on for
christmas so it doesn't really make
sense for him to visit me now because i
go home december 17th
um
the mdu some clips from oz to react to
is that always raining in the uk it's
either raining or cloudy it hasn't
rained like a ton here actually since
i've been here
but it's been like cloudy and like muggy
pretty much every day
do i play fortnite
no i do not
am i taking the dog home for christmas
no if i could do it again i wouldn't
have brought ellie until december
because
now i have to find a sitter for her here
so it's like
just another thing i have to do
otherwise i have to pay another 800 to
get her back in the country
um
tell that bro that's asking for advice
to get
what
the gun chasers what are you talking
about oh my goodness
um do i play any video games no i don't
except for sims i loved sims
um
if i felt like i would make money though
i could learn like
[Applause]
white people weather does that just mean
like pale
i can make money on twitch what would i
have to do like what would i have to do
on twitch to make money
i'm actually glad that i did this
because now i can
like i know i have to figure out this
black bar
am i into crypto no
guys i don't even have enough money to
in
invest in crypto right now like i spent
so much money like my entire savings on
this move
so you know feel free to drop a donation
in the chat if you know what i mean
i made friends yet um
yeah yes i accept super chats yes
they're encouraged actually
uh have i made any friends yet yeah i've
made some friends nothing like crazy but
like yeah some girls on the team are
nice
oh my gosh speaking of spending money
they just
emailed me my phone bill
uh you know what
i'm gonna deal with that later
okay all you have to do is make an
account on twitch and stream and when a
person follows you on twitch then you
get paid and your followers give you
donations on twitch
so i get paid for every follower
how much do i get paid
that doesn't seem right my cash app
you already know i'm about to pull this
up
oh my gosh it's saying i have to
reinstall it
what on earth
my paypal is hannahpearldavis gmail.com
and
okay you're trying to open an app that's
currently not installed the app will
install in the background i guess i
don't use cache app often
oh wait okay now it's open
[Music]
my cash app is
oh
hannah pearl davis h and you know what
i'll put it in the comments
um okay pearl is my middle name that's
where it came from
so i just
the nickname started in college there
was another hannah on the team so people
started calling me pearl and i just
really liked it
um okay
how do i pin it
i don't know how to
oh i just clicked it is that what it
does does it just say up now
well yeah well you can get three dollars
per follow but let's say if you have 3
000 followers and your 3 000 followers
will send you money to support your
stream
okay
so i can get three dollars per follow or
i will get three dollars per follow
well that's kind of why i did it was
because
um
i just figured there's there's less
pearls than hannah's and i just felt
like branding like
i liked just pearly things because i
could switch it with whatever i made so
like if i wanted to do like songs i
could do just pearly songs or just
pearly music or like pearly music or
like what like i felt like pearl and
pearly i could like move
and just hannah things it just didn't
have like the same ring to it
i don't know i just genuinely enjoyed
like
i just felt like and i felt like i could
do like pearls on my logo and that's
what i did it's like a pearl on the
outside
watch lingerie football
huh
do i watch sports
no but i would if people watched it
i'd watch damn near anything
if people watched it
like watched me watch it
[Music]
[Music]
who is a better athlete
oh my gosh well i have so many siblings
um it's funny because my
i thought what chicken did i throw away
my brother
austin
is actually probably the best athlete
out of all of us but he didn't really do
much with it like he didn't play in
college or anything
um but he's like the most naturally
athletic out of all of us um
my dog is snoring
can you see her
wait
see she's right on the floor there
the problem with reacting to music is i
keep getting in trouble with copyright
like
today i just reacted to
a video and i got blocked like i keep
getting blocked by music and i don't
understand why do some people not get
blocked and i always do and i'm like
what did i do wrong like why
okay i get playful teasing but what
about explicit
explic
explicitly talking dirty isn't it better
to get verbal consent when she has time
to think about it
what do you mean
verbal consent
like what what does that even mean
is it your nature to be competitive yes
and
they'll always talk about like
it's funny because in the manosphere
people will always talk about like super
feminine women
and like femininity and all that stuff
but i don't
i don't really consider myself super
feminine to be honest like i consider
myself more of a tomboy
um
like 90 of the time i wear sweats
i'm i'm super competitive like i like to
work hard i like to work like a lot if i
can
um
like i work hard at everything i
do i
like like sometimes i relate more to
guys with stuff and it's unfortunate
because
like
i don't know i just i feel like that's
not good right
but
[Music]
um successful streamers on twitch can
turn up
earn three thousand
to five thousand from their followers
and top streamers and earn more what
mean can and like what what it would it
typical twitch streamers make like
that's the question i'm just wondering
how much opportunity is you know
actually there
what are my thoughts on casual sex um
i don't think casual sex is like
especially i think it's especially bad
for women um
i think that
um
i don't know
i just i feel like casual sex is like
treating people like they're disposable
um and you're really just like using
each other so
i don't know i don't
[Music]
like i understand the whole like like
it's better for men because
of like pre-selection and all that stuff
but
i don't know i just really
i just really think it's bad for women
um
how am i doing on my mental health
huh
nobody's ever asked me that
um
i've been better like lately but
honestly it's been hard like
lately it's just like i'm alone
in a country like by myself
um
i'm kind of stressed like about money
um and i know like i have my parents and
like if i ever really needed money i
could go to them that's like a shitty
feeling you know
to be like 25 and still in a position
where like
like and i used to be fine like i used
to have like a lot of savings but
then i spent like just this move has
been so expensive and
like when i first got here i was just
catching up on like school on volleyball
because i was like three four weeks late
because i had to be in a wedding um
so i had to come late i don't know so
it's been like hard but
like i'm starting to see the light at
the end of the tunnel now
if i get my tick tock followers to
follow me on twitch that's where the
real money comes in
yeah if i could
um
what are my thoughts on prostitutes
um
i would never encourage someone to do it
but
i'm also like i think it should be
legalized to be honest um
but
like i don't really have strong opinions
on it
like i would never want to see it get to
a point where it's just like out in the
open like it is in vegas i wouldn't want
to see that everywhere um
like but
um
but i i have a hard time believing that
it's ever gonna go away
um so i don't know if there was a way we
could like kind of shelter like kids
from it and not have it like completely
in the culture
but
also
like protect the prostitutes
um
i don't know that sort of thing
[Music]
[Music]
um
casual sex treats people like disposable
commodities spreads disease and results
in kids out of wedlock and dysfunctional
parents
um
am i intp i don't know what that means
um i think that's a personality test
but i have no idea
if you go to the park with your guitar
and just be you and make tons of friends
and meet people that are into guitars as
well if i were there i would be writing
ideas to prep for your upcoming cd
um
it's a good idea if you know any parks i
could go to send them my way i guess
i mean i'm not in downtown london though
i'm in like
i am i'm like my address is in london
but i go to school at the university of
east london
so
um my personality type so i have just
done jordan peterson's test
i actually think i've taken that test
and i think
i don't remember what the
answer was i just remember i was the
same personality as obama and oprah one
of the times i took it
but i don't
i don't remember which one that was
but for jordan peterson's personality
test i was like pretty high in
agreeableness um
and i was like crazy high in enthusiasm
and
extroversion
like
um
can i take the 16 personalities test on
live
sure
actually that's a good idea
[Music]
let me close out of my million tabs
before i i'm like was i googling
anything embarrassing today i don't
think so but
okay let's see 16.
i've definitely taken this before but i
don't remember what my answer was
um
okay how do i share my screen
oh share screen
okay i'm not going to be able to see the
comments because i only have one monitor
so
if new people come in the chat and
they're asking questions um
tell them that because
oh actually i should share
the window okay
um oh wait actually i'm gonna pull it up
on my phone
um
really let me pull it up on this phone
because that way i can still see the
chat
oh wait that's my last video
um okay
[Music]
okay take the test it only takes 10
minutes
you regularly make new friends um i
would say like naturally yeah i make
friends pretty easy
um
you spend a lot of your free time
exploring various random topics that
pique your interest for sure that's like
what i do in this youtube channel seeing
other people cry can easily make you
feel like you want to cry too
no it's kind of awkward when other
people cry
um
you often make a backup plan for a
backup plan um i barely have a
first plan so
like i am not a planner um you stay calm
even under a lot of pressure
um i would say yeah
like i'm not really a warrior but
sometimes in volleyball
like i served out the other day when i
was like really close that made me mad
so i'm gonna do a little bit of great at
social events
you rarely introduce yourself and talk
to new people and mostly talk to the
ones you already know
um
[Music]
i would say
i rarely i would say disagree i'm pretty
extroverted
um you prefer to completely finish one
project before starting another no it's
a problem like i start way too many
projects you're very sentimental yes
you like
organizing school tools like schedules
and lists i do but i would say i'm
pretty disorganized as a person
so i feel like this is like misleading
because i use those tools because i'm
disorganized but i guess i'll put it for
the little bit
um even a small mistake can cause you to
doubt your overall abilities and
knowledge
not really
you feel comfortable just walking up to
someone you find interesting and
striking up conversation
i feel like
recently i've been so much more
introverted but like
normally in my life yeah um you are not
too interested in discussing various
interpretations and analysis of creative
work what does that mean
um
like i discuss on my youtube channel
different interpretations of stuff and
that's like creative works but i
wouldn't talk about like art
uh i'm gonna just put in the middle
because i don't really know what that's
asking
um you are more inclined to follow your
head than your heart
i'm really logical but at the end of the
day i'm still a girl like i'm still a
woman
so
like i'm still pretty emotional
but i'd say like for a girl i'm pretty
logical so
i'm gonna do like slightly agree
[Music]
um you prefer just doing what you feel
like at any given moment yeah that's why
i'm up at three freaking 10 in the
morning
oh my god i'm so bad at routines like
terrible
so i'm gonna put it
you
rarely worry about whether you make a
good first impression on people you meet
um
i would say disagree
you enjoy participating in group
activities
uh yes i love group activities
you like books and movies that
you can come up with your own
interpretation of the ending no it'll be
stupid
um
your happiness comes more from helping
others accomplish
things in your own accomplishments
i'm trying to think i really do enjoy
like helping people like i really enjoy
like talking to people about something
that they're passionate about but
i like i'm thinking about volleyball i
feel like if that was true i would have
coached
like if i really was passionate about
helping people i would coach but it just
sounded so boring to me
um so we're gonna do
i want to go in the middle because i
really do enjoy helping
people but more than my own i don't know
i'm gonna i'm gonna go a little bit to
disagree okay you are interested in so
many things that you find difficult to
choose what to try next agree you are
prone to worrying about things that take
a turn for the worse disagree
you avoid leadership roles in group
settings
oh my gosh
i realized that this is this is where i
really like to be i like to be second in
command i love i hate
having to make the decision and like
leading the group but i love helping a
strong leader
so
like
that that is like the role that i enjoy
greatly
like it so like when i'm on a team and
there's a girl that's very like
bossy and dominant but i respect as a
leader
that like i love like helping them out
with stuff
um
so
who would you guys say agree or disagree
then
um
i guess i guess i do avoid i would i'm
gonna put agree a little bit
um you are definitely not an artistic
type of person i'm a creative
um so i would say disagree
you would think the world would be a
better place if people rely more on
rationality and lessen their feelings
yeah i agree you prefer to do your
chores before allowing yourself to relax
i disagree but i'm trying to change that
um
okay
you enjoy watching people argue yeah i
love debates you
tend to avoid drawing attention to
yourself no i'm on youtube that's like
the definition of drawing attention to
myself
but but i do hate wearing clothes that
are like super attention-grabbing
and i hate like
there's oh my gosh
i hate
like i like being the center of a small
room but if there's like a ton of people
then i know too much
your mood can change very quickly i
agree um you lose patience with people
who are not as efficient as you
no not really
you often end up doing things the last
moment yeah
you've always been fascinated by the
question of what if anything happens
after death yes um
you usually prefer to be around others
rather than your own
than on your own
um
i do prefer to be around people but i
like to be around people with the same
interests as me so it depends on the
person but
um you become boy or bored or lose
interest when the discussion gets highly
theoretical disagree
um you find it easy to emphasize with a
person who experiences are very
different from yours i would say
agree
you usually postpone making final
decisions for as long as possible
i can think of times where i've been
early to a decision and late
i would say no i don't
but i'm gonna just do a little bit you
rarely second
guess the choices you've made oh my gosh
oh wait no disagree i second-guess my
choices all the time
um after a long and exhausting week a
lively social event is just what you
need
yeah but the right type of social event
but yeah
you and you enjoy going to art museums i
know
you often have a hard time understanding
other people's feelings
my boyfriend always says i do
but i feel like
i feel like i
often have a hard time understanding
other people's feelings
i don't say disagree i don't think i
think i can understand
um you like to have a to-do list for
each day
um
i usually have a weekly to-do list i'm
going to say agree a little bit you
really feel insecure or disagree i am
like the most insecure person i know um
you avoid making phone calls disagree
um you often spend a lot of time trying
to understand views that are different
from your own i would say agree um in
your social circle
you are often the ones who contact your
friend and initiate activities agree
if your plans are interrupted your top
priority is to get on track as soon as
possible
agree you're still bothered by your
mistakes you made a long time ago um
let's say agree
you rarely contemplate the reasons for
human existence disagree your emotions
control you more than you control them
oh that's hard
i'd say disagree uh
i'm so logical but i'm emotional still
okay you take great care not to look at
peop to make people look bad even when
it is completely their fault no if it's
if
disagree
your personal work style is closer to
spontaneous bursts of energy
yes when someone thinks highly of you
you wonder how long it will take for
them to feel disappointed in you
oh that would be the core agree
um you would love a job that take that
requires you to work alone most of the
time
uh
well i want to do youtube but i feel
like youtube's different because you're
always talking to people so i'll say
disagree you believe that pondering
abstract facility
philosophy
oh my gosh philosophical questions is a
waste of time
i disagree you feel more drawn to places
with busy bustling atmospheres and quiet
intimate places
say agree a little bit you know at first
glance how someone is feeling
i disagree i would say i'm not the most
observant person you often feel
overwhelmed
no i think i should feel more
overwhelmed than i do
you complete things method
methodology without skipping over steps
oh god disagree you're very intrigued by
things labeled as controversial agree
um
you would pass along a good opportunity
if so you thought someone else needed it
more
well who's the someone like for a
stranger no
my close family
i would say no probably not
not just not just anyone um you struggle
with deadlines
i think i'm good with deadlines i'm just
not
i'll say i'll say agree a little bit you
feel confident that things will work out
for you
yeah actually i do okay you guys ready
drum roll please
i'm the baiter
the debater i think this is not what i
got last time actually
i feel like i got a new one i get like
three every single time
is that what you said
no you said you knew it you said are you
an intp earlier
cap
i you said i
not e
was it a typo
but i actually i'm pretty sure i got a
different one last time because i got
whatever one oprah was
yeah i i got
whatever because i remember being like
oh i'm like cool
obama and oprah
um got the same thing so i don't
remember what it was but it definitely
actually i bet i could look and tell you
if i read this i'll tell you all the
ones
that i've gotten because i've gotten
more than one
pipes
wait um
so i've gotten the debater that's what i
got this time
um
okay i've gotten the protagonist
entp you know what i bet you i know why
it switched because i used to think that
i like did want because i always used to
want to be in leadership positions but i
realized like recently that naturally
that's like not
oh and i got the campaigner i did get
the campaigner once
i think that's it though like i think
because i switched the leadership
i might have gotten the entertainer once
i've taken this so many times but i
always forget what i got
but if i did it was like once not a lot
i know the three that i've gotten the
most was the protagonist the campaigner
and the debater like those are the three
um
yeah i like i don't even know what these
really mean so
maybe it does like i don't i got no dog
in this fight
um
it's just like
oh wait hold on
much
um does my dog need to go outside
the thing is they updated their
personality test yeah maybe they did
i definitely like i think i've
i always wanted to be like a leader in a
leadership roles but i think like over
the last couple years i've really
understood like where i bring the most
value on a team and like in an
organization
and it's definitely not the person
that's in charge of everything
i can do it like i definitely can but
wait ellie come here
i don't know what you're doing but i do
not trust you in my room
um
[Music]
come here come here
um
but i don't know because i used to hate
i used to literally hate that i wasn't
someone to like take charge and like in
volleyball you're kind of rewarded for
like yelling at people and like really
being the intense one in the gym and
just like naturally that's not
that's not me
and i used to literally hate it like i
used to hate it so much
but
honestly like
i don't really mind it now because i
feel like
i wouldn't be as likable and like i
wouldn't get along with people as much
if i wasn't so agreeable and that's like
the trait i realized that's what it was
like the girls that were more leadership
positions like tend to be more
disagreeable
but
okay i need to end this live actually
because
oh my god it's like 3 30 in the morning
so
all right guys thanks for coming on uh
this was fun
a fun time
and i will talk to you guys next time